jenny good morning how are you doing um
so i
am a mom of three little ones and um it
gets pretty chaotic in my house
and um i constantly find myself
responding to my kids
in anger um so i really need help
figuring out
how to change that because i know that
my anger is damaging
my relationships with my kids
how old are they um i have a
five-year-old a three-year-old and a
one-year-old whoo
so you're in the thick of it huh yes
tell me about your five-year-old um
well she is um
she's in kindergarten and she's very
quiet and barely says
a word outside our home um
and so she's always like on her best
behavior at school so
when she comes home she just kind of
lets it all out
there you go so what about your what
about your middle child
um so he
he actually is typically the happy one
but
um lately he he's just kind of been
really fussy and just kind of cries
about everything
and what about your wonderful place
where that's coming from what about your
wife um
so he's probably the most challenging of
all of them
he's extremely clingy he's never really
been a content baby
and um he's only happy when i'm holding
him or feeding him or playing with him
and so i can't
can't get anything done and i can't get
any quality time with my older kids
so um
what about dad is he present yes
good guy yes how
when i say present what does that mean
to you
um well he is
um he's very supportive i mean he is
always there he helps me whenever i need
help
so i mean he just you know has to work
during the day and so
um i'm just ready for him to be done
with work by the end of the day
and um yeah so
number one i want you to hear me say
loud and clear you're not crazy and
you're not
nuts okay
okay do you trust me
yes okay you have three humans
under the age of five i'm about to have
a five-year-old too
and whoa
and you've got two underneath that
so you are not nuts everything in your
house is crazy
everything feels out of place and
everything feels like
you are just reactive is that right
yes and so then you respond in
anger i want you to think of anger as a
gift
okay anger just points you towards
something that you care about
it just points you towards something
that matters to you that's important to
you
and so when you say you respond in anger
what does that mean
um well you know i get really
impatient and irritated and annoyed and
so i'm just i'm really short with them
so i guess this is my
harsh tone of voice when you find
yourself impatient
what do you want the other situation to
be
and what i mean by that is you must have
a picture in your head
of a clean kitchen or a
perfect perfectly ordered children
standing in a row
waiting for to to ask you what they can
do to help you with your day
or uh you want to finally take a shower
or you want your body to finally be
yours and not having people
clamoring you don't want to feel like a
you know like a garage anymore right
where people are just
using you as a as a as a space that
they're claiming as their own right
all those and you get short and
frustrated
what is the picture in your head what do
you want on the other side of that
um i guess i just uh
expect them to not
uh do the things they know they
shouldn't do you know but
the same things that happen every day um
um i just feel like it just repeats
itself over and over again and so
i guess that's just frustrating to me um
for sure
i want you to feel i want you to feel
totally at peace with the frustration
it's normal here's a couple of things
you can do and begin to work through
okay
so you can't control the fact that a
five-year-old's a five-year-old
that they think things are funny or
scary or loud
right you can give them firm boundaries
this morning my daughter was
screaming and i don't mean screaming i
mean like
heavy metal singer screaming at my son
for something i thought he was
had pulled a hatchet out and this was it
and i went up to see what was going on
and it was something that was so minor
and benign
and i just sat down and said you cannot
talk to my son like that
you can't talk to your brother like
right so there's some there's certain
boundaries
certain things you can't do and there's
certain things that are just
developmental
that are just three-year-olds and
one-year-olds and so the only thing in
that equation
you can control is you right
and if you wait until you're frustrated
or exhausted or somebody's been hanging
on you all day
if you wait until your three o'clock
plan
doesn't work out because one kid took a
nap too long or one was too short or
your husband had to stay at work later
if you wait until those moments then
that's like the fire's already out of
the barn right it's already burning down
your pasture
it's too late and so what i want to
challenge you to do is this
number one be really graceful with
yourself
often i find moms of one kid much less
three
the person you stop taking care of is
you
the person you stop asking what do i
need right now
is you and i know that sounds like a
privileged statement because some moms
would love to do things for themselves i
don't freaking have time i've got to go
work two jobs i've got to fill in the
blank
but i want you to start being kind to
yourself and start asking yourself what
do you need
how is putting on your oxygen mask today
going to help
and occasionally that means asking your
husband i need you to help me in this
way because i've got to go work out i've
got to go for a walk
i've got to shower alone for the first
time in however long
and i need you to adjust your work
schedule or
i need to call a friend over a few days
a week just to sit with my kids for an
hour
while i just act like a human for a
minute
or fill in the blank fill in the blank
and of course all this is messier
because of corona i get all that
but i want you to start thinking through
number one what are the things that you
need
not what are the things that i have to
do have to do have to do
in my house this is we've had some hard
conversations because my wife
has a picture of a kitchen that's always
clean always 24 7. like
i will not do anything after this until
that's done
and she realized but i need to do this
too
i need some quiet time i need some
writing time i need some exercise time i
need some fill in the blank time
so i want you to take the put the
pictures of the way you're trying to
keep things together right now that's
making you frustrated because you can't
make those pictures a reality because
you got
three miniature humans running around
i want you to put those down and say
what do i need number two
i want you to get with your husband and
actually come up with a tried-and-true
plan what is a what is a plan for a week
gonna look like
as opposed to reaction you can't control
reactive five
three and one-year-olds they just have
shorter naps sometimes they just don't
take a nap at all sometimes they just
have
rocket explosive diarrhea sometimes they
just fill in the blank
you can come up with a schedule and a
plan and that means you and your husband
are going to sit down
and you're going to plan the week you're
going to put it on a note card you're
going to put it in a
calendar you're going to put it in some
sort of semblance of
and that might mean meal planning that
might mean saying on monday hey husband
i need you to pick up
dinner these two nights or you're going
to come and cook but
plan these things ahead of time and it
makes so much less reaction
and then hold those plans really loosely
let him know hey at four o'clock i may
call you and say you're doing dinner
tonight and he's gonna have to roll it
because you got three miniature humans
you may call and say we are going out
tonight
because i got three minutes of humans
and i can't take another second of this
you may have to call a neighbor and say
hey so-and-so is still sleeping and i
don't want to wake him up
but i've got to go pick up such and such
and you've got to come up with a team
but
all that starts with the plan then the
third thing is
promise yourself we could get into this
deeper we're not going to on this show
your anger reaction is probably
something you watched and experienced
promise yourself that you will not pass
that on to your kids
promise yourself promise yourself jenny
you're not going to yell at your kids
you're going to come up with different
alternative ways to help them learn
different alternative ways you're not
going to pass that on to them so that
when
they're around their kids and friends
and family that's going to be their only
response mechanism too
that means you're going to have to learn
whether it's with a counselor whether
it's
in a agreement with your husband whether
it's reading the right book
it's you're going to have to learn and
practice non-reactive ways of responding
to your kids and that is
hard and it's lifelong
it's lifelong and then one final thought
your one-year-old is going to live
your one-year-old is going to live they
need to learn some boundaries and that's
hard
your other kids need your full attention
eye contact connection
and so there may be times when you have
to alternate nap times
you have to alternate play times you've
got to do some
creative scheduling there that's going
to make you exhausted but that each kid
is going to get their
connected time with you and it's going
to feel awkward but you're investing
time in the middle of the day that's
going to pay off at the end of the day
because you're not going to have fried
disconnected kids there
so that's a few thoughts a few ideas um
i hope people will respond in the
youtube comments with things that have
worked for them
right um feel free to send me some
emails
and i will circle back folks if you've
got things that work for you
the one glaring thing here is i'm not a
mom of three tiny little kids i've just
sat
and talked to them and met with them
over the years and it starts with grace
it starts with planning and it starts
with a commitment to not be reactive